[Music]
the next few months are set to be some
of the best ever for marvel maniacs with
both Captain Marvel and Avengers endgame
seeing white release whilst fans have
speculated as to how exactly the heroes
will defeat Thanos as well as how
Captain Marvel will play into the final
showdown recent set visits and
interviews with samuel l.jackson have
revealed what might happen now there may
be heavy spoilers here normally these
kind of rumors would be speculation
however with this coming directly from
Jackson it seems very likely so you have
been warned but in an interview with
Entertainment Tonight when discussing
Captain Marvel Jackson revealed the
Avengers are up against some really
really tough odds right now so now we
know that we need something that is as
powerful as Thanos and at some point
we'll find out how powerful she is and
all the things that she is capable of
she's one of the few people in the
Marvel Universe that can time-travel
this of course plays massively into fan
theories that state that the Avengers
will be traveling through time in order
to obtain the Infinity stones before
Thanos can it definitely seems possible
now especially with photos from the set
and this seems like a pretty big reveal
for how things will go down so what did
you think of this reveal and do you
think it will play into the ending
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out my fan theory
about the Avengers running scene from
the Infinity war trailer which will be
linked at the end of this video this is
the channel for people who are super
into superheroes so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]